so today we're going to cancel the most
underrated member of the squad ayanna
presley uh i call her underrated because
she's easily the craziest one of the
bunch even more so than aoc or ilhan
omar
yet she doesn't always get the credit
that her craziness deserves
demonstrating my point here she is on
the house floor yesterday introducing an
amendment
to lower the voting age to 16. here's
what she says
to immigration reform to climate change
to the future of work and minimum wage
our young people are organizing
mobilizing and calling us to action
they are at the forefront of social
movements and have more than earned
inclusion in our democracy
mr speaker 16 and 17 year olds
constituents of mine are supporting
their families
they are working not for enrichment or
to build a resume but because they have
no choice
they are attending school full-time and
taking care of loved ones in the midst
of the covered crisis
young people are contributing both to
the labor force and their local
economies
by paying taxes and yet they are
deprived of the opportunity to exercise
their right to vote
some have questioned the maturity of our
youth i don't
16 and 17 year olds today possess wisdom
and maturity
defined by today's challenges hardships
and opportunities
they deserve and demand a government
that is accountable to them
a government that values their voices
and understands the depth and breadth of
their lived experience
there it is lived experience everyone
take a shot
yes we must understand the depth of a 16
year old's lived experience
they're people of great wisdom she says
great maturity
their voices should be heard in our
democratic process they should have a
say
and all of these claims would be really
super convincing to me
if it weren't for the fact that i was a
16 year old once
and if i had never met any other 16 year
olds then maybe i could find this rosy
picture
believable but my experience both with
being 16 and being around 16 year olds
tells me that no
they are not wise and mature they are by
and large idiots
and i say that with no malice or
judgment i was the biggest idiot of them
all at 16.
i very often marvel at the fact that i
managed to live through the experience
of being 16.
at 16 especially if you're a guy you
will literally
risk your life just to amuse your
friends
like just getting a wow dude that was
awesome out of your buddies is enough
justification to do something that has a
75 percent chance of killing you
that's the kind of wisdom that a 16 year
old has okay
it's not nearly the kind of wisdom that
i have now as a 34 year old man
when i would never do anything that has
a 75 chance of killing me just to make
people laugh
it would have to have to be no more than
a 50 chance
there's also science behind this you
know your anecdotal experience
with teenagers and being a teenager is
backed by science
it's not a coincidence that we all have
this impression of teenagers
as impetuous impulsive hormonal
half-sane barbarians
science tells us that the prefrontal
cortex the region of our brain
that controls things like logical
reasoning discernment impulse control
all the things that we would normally
relate to wisdom
isn't fully developed until the age of
25.
so if you like me look back at yourself
from the age of like
15 to 24 and think my
god who was that person that person was
actually insane i was an actual lunatic
well this is why your executive brain
functions your capacity to be a
reasonable and mature adult
were not fully online
now you might object and say well by
this logic instead of lowering the
voting age we should raise it to 25 is
that what you're saying
yes exactly that's precisely what i'm
saying
precisely what we should be doing the
country would not by any measure benefit
from having 16 year olds vote ayana
presley would benefit
because her ideas and policies are so
stupid and destructive that most 16 year
olds
would find them appealing but the
country would not benefit
it also doesn't benefit from having 18
year olds vote there is simply no
downside to requiring people to grow a
little older
become a little wiser accumulate some
more lived experience
before they vote what's the worst that
could come from such a policy what's the
worst case scenario
a bunch of kids get their feelings hurt
storm off to their rooms
you won't let me vote well i hate you
i mean that might happen i can think of
plenty of downside to allowing
uninformed and unwise people to vote
we've been living through that downside
for decades
now with all that said
i would be willing to consider a
compromise here
in in an intelligent objection to the
points i've raised so far
is that sure most 16 year olds
are immature and stupid but then again a
lot of 36 year olds are too
there are many 56 year olds who are as
ill-equipped for the voting booth as the
average 16 year old if not more so
that's all true so my compromise would
be this similar to what i proposed in
the past
all voters must take a simple test
measuring their basic aptitude and how
informed they are
we'll be setting a pretty low bar with
the test starting small
questions like who is the secretary of
state what does the legislative branch
of the government do
okay stuff like that i say all voters be
required to take this test
any who pass can vote any who fail
cannot so if you're 16 and you pass fine
if you're 62 and you fail you're out
now i'd like to see voting requirements
that go far beyond this i think the
requirements
should be strict enough that millions of
current voters are ruled out i'd like to
see the numbers reduced by about 70 to
80 percent
that's what i think we should shoot for
i don't think voting should be a big
party that everybody is invited to i
think it should be a
something that only the most informed
most engaged most productive and mature
americans have the privilege to
participate in
i realize this idea is upsetting to a
lot of people but i don't care
and anyway i'm willing to compromise i'm
willing to lower the bar
so that all you have to do is pass a
test that any eighth grader
should be able to pass anyone who does
pass it votes
anyone who doesn't doesn't so what do
you say iona presley
can we strike a deal no we can't can we
because you want the uninformed to vote
you want people who are utterly clueless
to file into the polling stations
and drown out the votes of the informed
and the engaged
citizens that's the whole reason
why you're proposing this change that's
also the reason
along with a bunch of other reasons why
you're canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content